I had this boyfriend whose name is John
Eric Hexum and he put a prop gun up
against his head and shot it and it blew
a piece of his skull the size of a
quarter into the middle of his brain and
no brain dead and a prop gun for
shooting a blank yeah oh yeah though
yeah if you put it here it probably
wouldn't okay but it was here how did
you
cope through the the shooting I really
almost couldn't believe it was happening
and then I wrote it in journals like I
feel like John Eric is a ticking time
bomb and I don't know when he's gonna go
off and what was really weird was he
died a week later I did go do Ayahuasca
because there's so many amazing things I
kept researching about it and in that I
was able to go back to that moment lying
in that bed with my boyfriend who shot
himself and I remembered a message his
message was I believe in you
go do this that go do these things you
want to do it's almost like he said you
can do this and that was way back at the
beginning of my career